[Applaus]
[Musik]
christine hug wurde vor 42 jahren
geboren und als knabe er zu doch weder
die wohl behütete kindheit die steile
karriere im militär noch die erfüllten
lebens träume von eigenheim und familie
vermochten das leben ehrlich schön zu
machen
christine fühlte sich nie wohl als man
doch erst nach 37 lebensjahren fasst sie
den mut die frau zu sein die sie ist
angst sie dass es auch gesellschaftlich
nicht akzeptiert ich oder ich habe ja
selber kecke das ist das abartige ist
dass das dass das des negativs ist und
damit verbunden natürlich eine stimme
akzeptiert werde ausgeschlossen
angst vor zurück wie es sich im prinzip
kann ich mir vorstellen dass alte mal da
kann ich mir vorstellen dass auch die
frauen einfach weitermachen nicht
vorstellen konnten
[Musik]
wir sind gerade
aus dem kind von damals ist eine frau
geworden heute mit 42 möchte sie dass
frau seien in vollen zügen genießen
christine steht erst in ihrem fünften
lebensjahr als geoutete trans frau davor
wurde sie von außen als mann
wahrgenommen und hat sich wie ein mann
verhalten
wann ist man nun eine frau wie definiert
sich die frau von heute und welches
geschlecht hat eigentlich unsere seele
diese fragen begleiten christine schon
ihr leben lang heute hält sie als
expertin vorträge zu diesen themen
[Musik]
[Applaus]
doch ganz herzlich willkommen kräftig
kmus sowie gestellt jetzt ist
berufspraxis zweiter stelle mit der
sache dass ausweitet aber mir ist
wichtig dass man sauber und vor allem
können wir
unterstellen
was macht so ist dass man sich ebenfalls
frage führt ob man als frau geboren ist
oder dass man sich als trainer fehlt was
ich dass wir genug zeit das zähler
solche krass geschlecht hat ob sie
arbeitet schlechter und dass ich beides
vorhanden dass ich etwas von mir seit es
hat eigentlich jedem menschen hat weiter
wo kriegen sind wo ich trainiere sind
und wo unterschiedliche völker mit und
wieder per persönlichkeit sich danach
heraus wirkt
christina kommt im mai 1980 als erstes
von zwei kindern auf die welt und
bekommt den namen christian hug
die familie lebt das konventionelle gute
leben am stadtrand von zürich die mutter
ist hausfrau der vater polizei und
militär offizier
niemand ahnt dass im kopf des jungen
blondschopf bereits damals grundlegende
fragen der geschlechtsidentität kreisen
[Musik]
während primarschulzeit habe ich schon
sperrig getankt
er sagt nur so hätte ich damals der
zauberstab durchaus bescheid bis meine
frau ganz klar
für mich wenig sie ja das geld nicht
will sich jetzt anders also muss jetzt
sein
[Musik]
wie geht man damit um wenn man schon als
kind merkt dass man gern anders wäre als
man ist die angst ist nie ein guter
berater und doch begleitet sie einen in
genau solchen situationen
nur heimlich getraute sich christian ab
und zu ein kleid seiner mutter
anzuziehen und damit sein tiefes
bedürfnis zu stille
[Musik]
wieder ab
da hatte ich mir wie er selbst ist nach
wie vor
das steigert sich dann training und dann
bin ich wahrscheinlich einfach doppelt
falsch gewickelt dann muss ich das jetzt
dementsprechend anpassen und lernen und
dann funktioniert es und war schon in
den anhang und familie raus doch dann
verschwindet eine dauerkarte von ali k
[Musik]
geprägt vom eigenen vater und dessen
leidenschaft fürs militär schlägt
christina in jungen jahren den weg zum
berufssoldaten ein und legt eine steile
karriere hin
innert weniger jahre wird sie zum
oberstleutnant und damit zum
kommandanten eines 300 köpfigen
panzerbataillons
konzentrieren und zwar sechs militärisch
oder 600 konzentrieren des studiums
trendresist aber parallel klopfen mit
dem zeitpunkt in der hec nicht per se
als kompensation haltung
gegenüber dem kunden somit können ab
sofort
einige dann kommt es mal vorsichtig aber
sie sind natürlich dass ich mir sehr
klar will man hat sich damit mit der
frage auseinandersetzen sondern steuerte
sie hat sich die aufgabe versuchsmäuse
und uns heute wieder zu und hat keinen
und fachlicher konzentrieren und hat
sich der frage um sich selber in einem
gewissen rahmen ihnen für einen markt an
einem fest des militär museums hilft der
damals 27 jährige christian mit und
präsentiert verschiedene panzer unter
den besucherinnen ist auch tanja sie
steigt so christian in den kalten rauen
panzer und mit ihr wird dieser
schlagartig zu einem ort der liebe
plötzlich scheint das ganz normale
sorgenfreie leben nur noch ein atemzug
entfernt zwischen der familie bevor
erste blick geht ihm im block ratti
versinkt sie sollten ich ärgere mich der
tanja ein mensch kann etwa auf die
persönliche tabelle unglaublich viel
gemeinsam hat wovon art und wie es im
eigeninteresse
manchmal einfach als person ein super
tor der genfer
auch für die zehn jahre ältere tanja ist
nach diesem nachmittag im panzer klar
dass sie den menschen ihres lebens
gefunden hat
da ich nie
italienisch von meinem arm gespürt habe
sich für eine zu große
frage in sachen eine frage
beantworten also wirklich ansehnlich
philosophieren und das ist so kurz will
ich sie so unglaublich kurz will ich das
match total
unterschätzt das irgendwie stung unter
vier stunden vergangen
mexikanische hauptstadt am panzer
und das ist eigentlich täter den moment
seabourn quest
mit damit an maritimer familie oder sexy
wird richtigen in einer woche spürte war
dies nach einem treffen verabredet ist
erster
italiener seit kann ja wo bist du nummer
die ganze technik sucht
die beiden heiraten nur wenige monate
später und gründen mit der geburt der
gemeinsamen tochter julia eine familie
[Musik]
halt
mit dem eigenen haus auf dem land und
drei pferden hat sich die familie hug
ihren eigenen lebenstraum erfüllt nach
außen hin ein bilderbuch leben im innern
des damals noch als man lebenden
christian tut sich jedoch ein seelischer
abgrund auf
bis dahin
fertig gemacht
für mich ist klar hätte ich so nach dem
motto ja jetzt soll endlich partnerin
fürs leben gefunden und ich völlig raus
jetzt ganz klassische die finther und
für mich ist ein
denn dann gibt sich dann also mit der
eine komische gedanken kommt ist noch
offen
ist ob sie
also das heilen familienleben das ist
sieben jahre sind
vergangen ist
lebensträume anführungszeichen hat man
hat mir wurde verwirklicht sie und hat
macau und ich mussten gleich bleibender
feld
es fehlt an nichts im leben
und doch fehlt irgendwie alles
das wahre ich es brennt will raus
zu lange wurde es unterdrückt und
missbilligt
christine kann nicht mehr die kräfte die
an der risen sind zu stark
sie muss eine entscheidung treffen
ungeachtet dessen wen sie alles
verlieren könnte
eine ohnmacht macht sich breit
die gedanken kreisen unaufhörlich wer
bin ich wer will ich sein und was
riskiere ich zu verlieren
der stets aufgestellte und aktive
christian leidet zunehmend an einer
starken lust und antriebslosigkeit
fühlt sich fehl am platz falsch sie
schmiert die cracks vor allem viele
jahre wo man ein teil für sich selber
unterdrückt und wagner hat
also wenn ich heute einfach so
weitergemacht hätte und das nicht
beachtet hat derweil eine depression
geschlittert und zwar relativ tief time
machine
[Musik]
auch tanja fällt in dieser zeit auf wie
sich ihr mann verändert sie befürchtet
dass er eine affäre mit einer anderen
frau hat in dem moment weiß christine
entweder sie rückt mit der wahrheit
heraus oder alles geht in die brüche
auch sie selber ich habe damals ihre
versuche maligen wird die gedanken und
das kann dann einen brief aus sich
festhalten
sie ist aber wirklich eintreten dass ich
mit werkfeuerwehren gegangen
angst im moment in einer völlig
unbekannten situation wo man nicht weiß
wie sie gott ob sie eskalierte welche
richtig funktioniert die ich ganz extrem
mir immer der regierung
[Musik]
christine spricht in dem brief an ihrer
ehefrau zum ersten mal aus was sie seit
der primarschule beschäftigt ich bin
eine frau in einem männlichen körper ich
bin kein mann ich will kein mann sein
sie hinterlegt den brief und geht
arbeiten
hat sie am abend nach hause kommt redet
sie mit ihrer frau über ihr wahres ich
und da ich habe dass ich
etwas haben was rund die zuschnitte und
nenne ich die ich
nicht alles richtig
quasi vor der tür gestanden und denkt
jetzt möglich
zb automotive
akustisch jetzt das geschäft sollte was
ich jetzt also geschminkt mit perücke
und high heels und
[Musik]
ich
dachte
ja
wirklich stattfindet sind stark und
hätten wirklich berater kongo
[Musik]
das vom gericht
recht aktiv das für
das abspringt ist 17 meter hohen mont
tablette tapfer
da ich plötzlich mehr bewusst worden
christian schmückten im wieder
feststellen
christian 40
jahren
als ich
die psyche
und das ist
wirklich
betrug
orientierungslos völlig sie
und das ist dass ich
in einer stadt prozess begleitet
trotz aller verlustängste gibt es für
christine kein zurück mehr sie fängt
sofort mit der hormontherapie an und
entscheidet sich früh für eine
geschlechts angleichen der operation
christina weiss dass alles was jetzt
noch auf sie zukommen mag niemals so
schmerzhaft sein wird wie die
unterdrückung ihrer selbst während so
viele jahre
[Musik]
der hormon ist auf jeden fall nach der
zweite pubertät von gemacht einfach
eklig kraft und viel schneller aber es
hat sehr viel einerseits körperlich wo
die ganzen umstände stattfindet am 17 im
empfinden und die gefühle was einiges
wird das ist der unterschied zwischen
männlichen und weiblichen hormon können
es auch mal zu
warum man
kann ja nie geschrieben das freut mich
dass firmen die immer sagen dass das so
ich
ganz und hilfsbereiten ist
die familie der in taktischen
verhalten auch spielfreude
aber du hast dir einsetzung der business
woche wieder den baustellen oder bauen
was horst und leben auch
durchaus auch brown hat das
dann kann julia
das ist auch sehr
verschlossene 20 doch der
stets machen
hey ich
bereue es nicht das ist
erst zu spät gemacht haben will der
wesentliche schritt ob das wesentliche
von mir jemand sagen ist prima gemacht
weil es wahrscheinlich nicht so der epc
kommen und juliane dass meine tochter
monika und vor dem
heroin das überhaupt titan ist erster so
sport gemacht
mit der seite der wahrscheinlich nicht
und das wäre
unglaublich viel was für mich ich habe
viel bedeutet hätte dein tod kaufte
wow
faktisch
als julia von der tradition ihres papas
erfährt ist sie acht jahre alt
geändert habe sich sagt ja nichts wie
sie sagt außer dass papa jetzt
nach dem ja
von der couch
neben der familie war die armee schon
immer ein wichtiger ankerpunkt in
christines leben
auch hier muss sie sich als trans frau
outen und damit rechnen ihren job zu
verlieren denn die schweizer armee steht
er für konservativ patriarchalisches als
für modernes gedankengut
der staatsschutz 40 respektive 40 hat
straße vom im labor große
bandbreite schnellstraße gott ist eine
sanfte linkskurve gab hier weg und die
direkt linkskurven ihnen gott rechts
krise sdram plötzlich weg
wo irgendwo im gebüsch ihnen
verschwindet völlig ist ungewiss und das
stört sich für sinnbildlich gesehen und
alles der verstand seite links das ist
bequem und
gefühl sagt nein da muss jetzt rechts
zurück
[Musik]
das militär gegangen bin ich so
verfallen vorteil sieht matschie will wo
ich damals mit dem militär angefangen
haben hätte ich zum beispiel der wunsch
druckt optik wobei auch sie sind was
frau garner könne gar das ist erst ein
paar jahre später ist das café damals
noch rekrutiere kaiser kampftruppe bei
unseren teil das gab noch einmal frauen
ist der zugang verwehrt
heute dürfen frauen in den kampftruppen
dienen jedoch gilt trans identität im
schweizer armee reglemente theoretisch
immer noch als untauglichkeit grund
branche dem sinnen und wirklichkeit
grund sie beruflich in der musik macht
weil sie gesagt hat bis dahin
niveau wurde vor betroffen über das man
vg hätte und man sagt ja im schlimmsten
fall ihnen ja man wird tatsächlich zum
schlusskurs werden im ausführbar dann
müsste ich mit einer besonders
kritisch für mich der punkt ist
klassisch das bin ich schon habe ich
habe jetzt so lang detail von mir fern
öffnet man das jetzt konsequent sind der
fotos sind das konsequenzen nichts das
ist wäre hätte ich
sagen einfach länger vermögen in der
apotheke und wenn das konsequenz ich
dann muss ich sie trage zwei sachen
sonntag im nachhinein kommen und
stellvertreter bis alle miteinander
einfach nur von schönen status martina
förster maxi
statusmeldung inter dann wenn es
ernsthafte probleme gibt wo dazu führt
dass ihr euren auftrag nämlich ein
weiterer führer oder wenn er gerade
wieder anders zur hand
und nur dann
und stimpfach denen die status
interessieren jemand wusste dass ich
wirklich das problem wenn er hilfe
braucht wohnen im saarland leser
mit einem fall
[Musik]
das immer wieder die klassische
rollenbilder angelangt wie soll es jetzt
komisch sie eine frau kriminalität auf
einmal hat das seine berechtigung und
ich bin deshalb berechtigung sondern es
geht darum was ist für ihre person was
hat sich für kompetent sondern wir
bringen sie die hypo
kann man sich nicht noch
die akzeptanz hat mit peter bestärkt
mich in sie und das ist im endeffekt
ihnen für mich sehr positiv gesehen es
ist es ist positiv dass akzeptiert
worden und es ist eigentlich wieder
gegangen respekt für mich ist fast immer
wieder kommen billiger da die last
frei jährige offen können sie und hatte
das gefühl dass ich vieles auch an ihnen
es ist schwierig per se und du setzt das
ja ruhig einen überbringe situation
übersicht
über gewalt und macht den charakter
haben ihr charakter billig wie möchte
ich sie im prinzip hat sich das
erscheinungsbild kärnten ist das foto
sei es ein sehr schönes bild und
erscheinungsbild im charakter verpasst
hat und nicht umgekehrt
das stimmt mir eigentlich positiv ist da
nichts zeitrahmen erlaubt
unsere gesellschaft frauen und die
jüngere ist das nimmer so
trainiere vorurteils man es vielleicht
bei älteren oder eher der fall ist
sollten sich es wird selbstverständlich
um sicher drin zieht dass es selbst
endlich verwerten
[Musik]
christina habe sich den rang des
oberleutnants nicht ab verdient weil sie
ein mann gewesen sei sondern weil sie es
konnte dass sie heute hier stehe sei
keine milde gabe sie habe es sich
verdient ist sie überzeugt
[Musik]
manchmal so scheint es ist es wohl
besser staub aufzuwirbeln als aus angst
bewegungslos staub anzusetzen
[Musik]
christines eltern haben ihren beiden
kindern stets die liebe und geborgenheit
geschenkt die man sich wünscht das hat
sich auch nach christines outing nicht
geändert
die eltern leben heute getrennt haben
aber zu christina ein gutes vielleicht
sogar ehrlicheres verhältnis
hallo du hast diesen look und
[Gelächter]
julia im schnitt doch nein hier ist noch
bitterer die zweite heißt jetzt schon
die ganze woche zeit
es war nicht planen
naja ist man am sonntag den sieg und für
ein nachweis bleibt also zu nachgiebig
ist die zeit noch bitter lassen
aber ich habe jetzt dass ich dass ich
das auto ja genau ich ja also ja dass
ich als erste mal gibt es sie
[Musik]
[Applaus]
wenn sie jetzt bahn wird ab oktober hat
der hand wenn sie
reinkommt und soll unter tochter
mit dem namen
shape ist jahr lang spricht diesmal
nicht ganz so
hoch
ja natürlich
jetzt
richtig an seiten und und jetzt
plötzlich halten sondern christine
krummhorn ist ein film für mich
bist du schließlich bei friedrich dass
ich
lange zieren drei kreise auch und nach
von der das dungeon das dem film ich
eben passend dass
das sehen wir darin sehen ob sie
das sehr wichtig mehr auf dem motorrad
das bei den
tempi passati
mami das stück ohne können
wo bin ich denn sie nicht aber die phase
wo krieg empfunden hat
gesagt ja das also dass ich das ich dass
ich etwas gesagt dass
das
ist meistens der fall dann hat man nicht
dass ich weniger vordringen möchte sie
meistens ja ich
kann über mich reflektiere die gedanken
sind frei und wo ich
mich
immer wohler
eigentlich
also sich sehr ausgeprägt
ja
das klassisch männlichen bild das ich
das ist starke selbstbewusste luft hatte
ein interesse hat wenn ich darf man
macht sport militaire entsprechen die
führungsverantwortung was hast du recht
aber das sind so eigentlich über liefere
die rollenbilder vorigen woche sind aber
nicht unbedingt eigentlich oder nein
wohl nicht unbedingt womöglich mit der
realität gar nichts zu hören und
trotzdem wird die gesellschaft eu
fakturiert oder diese gesellschaft
betriebene sind und dementsprechend
versucht man dann irgendwo unbewusst
deine bilder trotzdem zu entsprechen
oder seinem je eine bewusste seite und
das fand mit clean ist auch genau das
aber das fängt mit sachen wie zieht man
sich aber wie ich mir wie hat man sich
bei visp vs hat man sich interessieren
oder
nötig völlig blödsinnig und ich denke
dass ich das ist es wo man sich
permanent man sich in der frage was sind
die rollenbilder überhaupt woher komödie
und und umfasste zwar habe ich so sind
jedoch wieso sind sie so wie sie sind
und münchen
sicher nur schüler dem anstich vom
vor die presse um das nach wie vor
der krise angeht sieht sie hat jetzt
einfach das bedürfnis offensichtlich
braucht sie und
verschiedenste sind sind durch das was
bin ich froh bin und sage lockert im
übrigen hab jetzt christine sind mehr
als überrascht sie sind ja nicht
verstört sie haben doch
irgendwie dazu
wie soll ich das jetzt ordne ich denke
das wichtigste ich zum patent
diesbezüglich können akzeptiert zweiten
ist dass man einfach total sich selber
richter dass man da nicht
jetzt irgendwer bis auf andere jahr
fängt eigene probleme auf andere
projekte ihrer wo der logischerweise
wieder zu kommen sondern sich selber ich
dass man offen ist das man zu sich
selbst und das eigene bett ein anderen
ihnen völlig natürlich überbringt
christine sagt sie habe seit ihrem
outing vor vier jahren keine schlechten
reaktionen erlebt
für ehefrau tanja ist die situation eine
andere sie lebt heute nicht das leben
das sie sich immer gewünscht hat
von außen als lesbisches paar gelesen zu
werden macht ihr immer noch mehr
[Musik]
der christus christina und
b2 und
grünen kollegin oder das letzte spiel
was auch immer das gar nicht so eine
rolle aber dann im gespräch
ob das noch dass ich das trikot also
komische sinnvoll
jetzt wird
spannend trug sich auch nicht unbedingt
mit toten fischen wieder aber es ist
spannend und deine tanja aber dass das
kleid und stellen so flug zwischen
moment ja was ist genau wie sie
umgebracht wird
aber
das
ist vielleicht auch
ganz ist eigentlich
mag
[Gelächter]
ja dass ich dass sich stars und denkt an
die wirklichen bedürfnisse oberen krams
klar sei was situation ist und einfach
wirklich gespürt wie die vergangenheit
dass das einfach nicht und es gibt auch
keine komische frage zeigt aber auch
opfer erschwere das erste mal mit die
situation überhaupt
keine angst das ist jetzt völlig nicht
nötig das
mittel will
respektive 2 erfahren dass es durchaus
wichtige spiel durch und durch dritte ja
es ist sich die keine gewisse die
größten begrünen und
verständlich sache wo als normal an
gefährdet und wo automatisch zurück
folgen der grund wie man mit mut und wo
sonst als gesellschaftlich keine geholt
wird und wenn sie selber anders ist dass
das nicht bloßstellen ist sondern dass
das wirklich unverständnis hilft zum
zeigte sich das schon nicht werden sich
aber auch für zustand ist und macht für
andere ligen einfacher zu verstehen
mein
größter traum hat die mini heutigen
situation
jedes wochen vorstellen wirklich nicht
das war vor 20 jahren absolut und
dankbar für mich
liebt und nicht
ja es ist so wie sie
kriege
mit der julia mit dieser tochter und
umweg und den
japaner christine
lieblingsmenschen
und
es ist einfach sehr spannender prozess
wegen mir immer neuen prozess befinden
also das ist es auch was das vorstellen
vielleicht wie
wenig hat verwickelt die ganze tour an
gültige
dort mal verloren war ich ja immer nur
dann sind sie im körper
es ist
jetzt die viele jahre mit keiner
wirklich
so wie man es kennt und es ist ja
sexuelle themen sind kapitel wenig
appetit das noch immer kann hätte ich
mich als lesbisch bezeichnet vielleicht
von sony cea
willen der fraktion in der hand ihr
bezirk und ich bitte alle bezirk wohnen
bin und das spielt für mich
ja das
damals hat so ist sie halt relativ
veranstalter ist es warum frauen
und
männer
und dass
das haus nicht mit mir bin ich bin
dafür habe ich frage mich langsam
schlussendlich im moment leider nach wie
weichmacher dazu
und teils klapper genießen
am besten verhindern
wären nur verordnungen
ausstellen
foto stadt land ihre
reaktion vor der foto julia ist wirklich
extrem
erwachen sie viel erwachsener sie dass
vor allem erwachsene billig ist und dass
man jetzt eher peter pander nach indien
will sie sind vermutlich weniger
vorbelastet durch irgendwelche haltige
es vermeintlich müsste sie sollten sie
in einer situation wie sie und ziehen
ein mensch und und urteile nicht sondern
sondern nehme das ist und das haben
jetzt mit julia ganz extrem gemerkt und
geschätzt koch wie sie das gemacht hat
also wirklich im inneren völlige
klarheit eigentlich sei das anders du
bist ja wieder hindu und
je größer
woking daran
dass ich meine große liebe der
abschnitte
die anti kostet jetzt nur die begriffe
und gefragt und privat finanz ag hat im
mit nana und nein ich habe extra auch
weil ja gemeint die bauabnahme
gearbeitet
zu haben wir das team mit vier fragen
willst du nicht beliefert das ganze
ist einfach so
dass
ihm auch die einst gemacht ich genau
diese fotos zu machen bankrott
eine wie körper
[Musik]
manchmal hält sich beim nicht und
wahrscheinlich nicht da
also schön
[Musik]
das jedenfalls rät die haben mit unserer
mannschaft
die dank silva hat juli am start
also ich wünsche mir dass mir ist es
spannender lappen atmen
ich freue mich auf die herausforderung
in meinem
magen wenn die auf der der wagen
weg zu realisieren es geht nur filmstar
und ausgeschlachtet neutraler
schlussendlich wir haben wieder familie
probiert zu kleinen lieblings mensch
kann nicht sagen dass ich jetzt mein
lieblings mann und ohne
lieblingsmenschen
eingespannt schwierig ist um einen tag
etwas wirklich ganz furchtbar
ideal oder mit minenwerten vorstellig
oder wie man eine
begegnung am schönsten wenn wir alle
zusammen im bett liegen und
essayist
[Musik]
die entscheidung getroffen haben ist
absolut die richtige entscheidung für
mich aber nach dessau ist ja normal wie
saba
nicht wissen wie es noch einen zweiten
versuch noch einen start wissen sache
was die zukunft bringt weiß niemand so
genau es scheint dass christine tanja
und julia eine liebe verbindet die jeden
sturm zu bewältigen vermag
auch wenn sich die hülle wandle und die
welt sich verändere die seele seid doch
stets die gleiche
[Musik]